So, the other day, we were covering the
Oreo, and I made a bit of a prediction.
I said that if Anisa kept talking about
Nick, he would stop covering her. He
would run. And I actually thought he
would respond to the most recent talk
and then stop. I didn't think he would
be so transparent as to stop
immediately, but he did. So, Nick has
immediately stopped covering Anisa
because of the recent fight. It's pretty
It's pretty transparent. So, I want to
go through some of it here, guys. Let's
play first of all and not my clip. Let's
play this and not do that. He would have
to do that now. But, make no mistake, if
Anisa keeps talking about him,
he will stop covering them. If Anisa
keeps talking [__] about Nick in her
streams,
he will stop covering them. That is
absolutely undeniable because Anisa is
not saying things that make her look bad
when she does this. If she's not up, and
she's just like talking [__] on him, he
will freak out and not want to give it
oxygen and not want to have his audience
know that it's happening. He will just
He will literally back off. He will
literally back off. They could get him
to stop covering them so quick. He does
not want a fight. He certainly does not
want to fight where other people might
actually be able to get licks in against
him. He never wants that. He wants to be
background character jerking Ethan off
while Ethan does all the work. That's
what he wants to do. So, the moment
Anisa starts talking about him too much,
he will back off. Absolutely 100%. No
doubt in my mind. No doubt in my mind. I
believe he's already saying like
I think he said something on stream
recently like Oh, what
The iDubbz content is just getting a bit
much. I need to catch up on all the
content I'm backlogged on. So, watch out
for that, guys. Watch out for Nick
hopping off the iDubbz train.
If So, he had already said that. This
clip goes up on the 23rd of March. This
stream is from the next day. So, we're
going to watch a bit of this.
>> He's live. I have to embarrass my
husband. I have to embarrass my husband.
That's what I'm saying.
Are we ever getting the collab with
Tana? You know, I
>> So, in theory, guys, this should have
been the stream where he responds to
that Anisa stuff where Anisa was talking
to him. And you can see here, he watches
a video called Anisa Jorma, iDubbz's
wife, gets baited uh gets rage baited by
Channel Points for 10 minutes.
Okay?
But, he does not watch the video posted
on that exact same channel like 24 or 16
hours earlier,
which was Anisa talking about him and
Chad for like 20 minutes. So, he watches
that and he turns it off early cuz it's
total nontent. So, he chooses to watch
that, which he ends up turning off,
instead of the video that is directly
about him and drama he's been involved
in. And he tries to prime his audience,
I believe somewhere around this
timestamp,
uh into why he's not covering this [__]
anymore.
It's so funny. It's so funny.
>> He smokes came came back out with a CTE
comment. Let's read it. Dude, is How is
this chatter still there? How is he
Dude, they figured him out within
seconds. They're like, you know what?
Derail my whole stream.
>> I approved it. Blessed is what a [__]
says when he has CTE and then denies it.
Peace out, iFlubs.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, he came across
>> That was a notably cringe exit. I got to
be honest with you. This is one of the
examples of like the troll is creepier
not creepier cringier than the troll.
Ed the troll Ed. Us is like a uh Yeah,
that was that was actually not good.
What do you call that like uh like a
high school bully or
>> one before iDubbz saying that. I just
need the part where he talks about the
part I'm starting to subscribe to the
theory that they're actually [__]
right now and they literally just need
the detractors to keep pushing their
tiny streams.
Because when they don't talk about drama
cuz they don't want to talk about iDubbz
doesn't want to talk about drama. Anisa
probably does. I would believe that,
right? I think that they legitimately
are in a bad situation and I didn't
think it was that bad before until I saw
this.
Because why would Guys, I just think
they're in like a bad situation. They're
desperate to try to get people to talk
about them. I think they're just
desperate for any people to talk about
them. So, I'm not covering them anymore.
So, I'm not covering them anymore. Now,
don't think about how this is
suspiciously timed with Anisa talking
[__] about me, with Anisa saying that
that I'm a fat disgusting weirdo. Don't
think about that, guys. Don't think
about that. This is because uh they're
really desperate.
They're really desperate. Um and sure I
was going in on them for being desperate
and broke a year ago, but no, now
they're really desperate and broke. So,
now I have to stop covering them. So,
now I have Now I have to stop.
But, dude, why does the [__] iDubbz
cry out in pain as he strikes back?
That doesn't make any sense to me. If
you wanted this stuff to stop, you would
just stop talking about it and there'd
be no segments to cover. You wouldn't
sit here and continue to like
Right, because when they talk about the
drama, you always cover it. Don't you,
Nick?
That's pretty clearly what's being said
there.
Is if they they want to Thing is, I
cover all of it. I cover all of it. So,
if they want it to stop, they've just
They've got to stop cuz I'm not
stopping. I'm covering all of it. I If
they give me If they give me content to
cover,
if they give me content to cover, then
I'll cover it.
But, not this one. But, not this one
video. But, not this Not this one vid of
Anisa.
That one, we'll give that one a miss.
>> putting yourself like letting yourself
get clip farmed in this way.
Can we leave Ian in 2026? That's
probably a sure bet.
Dude.
>> It's only March.
So, I'm not going to leave him like
right now, but
I could see that. Not Not right now, but
I'm out soon.
>> Claymation.
Claymation Benjamin Netanyahu with gravy
on his neck. Dude, [__] Reddit would
be like, "Is this AI?"
Do you guys like claymation Benjamin
Netanyahu with gravy on his neck?
I was trying to get him trying to get an
illustration of the gravy on the neck,
if you know what I mean.
>> So, wait, is it AI actually? I'm
actually Now, I'm I'm the Redditor. I am
the Redditor.
>> Sis. For context, they were talking
about people who don't like woke stuff
and how pathetic and cringe and creepy,
etc. these people are.
>> Ooh.
>> His name is It's a Gundam. He's an anti
He really is AI.
>> This is literally so There's nothing
happening in this stream. It's amazing.
Nothing happening in the stream. It's
Ian being like lame as [__] like Oh,
here's my epic Netanyahu joke. Okay,
good stuff, Ian. Good stuff, man. And
then Nick just going like like literally
not even saying adding anything, no
worthwhile commentary. It's not any kind
of analysis. It is literally just like
canned phrases. Just firing off canned
phrases.
Dude, you burn. You're lying. It does
sound like a person though. Oh, [__]
You're right.
>> How the [__] does iDubbz not know who
It's a Gundam is? Did he miss the
Pokimane controversy that
Oh, how do you know that It's a Gundam
is? Anyway, let's move on, okay? Let's
see the Anisa bit. So, he goes and
watches an Anisa video, guys. Not the
one about him that was on the exact same
channel posted hours beforehand.
A different one.
here or most of it is just somebody
[__] up the chat for free.
Like chat XP. Yeah, imagine if you had
like the chat XP thing and you could
cash that in to ruin my show.
And I don't get a single dollar for
doing it. That's essentially what you're
about to watch.
I did with coffee.
Uh but in the '90s, every
>> Dude, posture check.
>> one would be calling them Ian's old
catchphrase. Ooh.
Oh, dude, did she just
Dude, she said Ian's catchphrase and
then just [__] squirmed because of
the I cuz she realized what they meant.
>> be calling them Ian's old [laughter]
catchphrase. Ooh.
She read that, didn't realize where it
was going. This is This is what he's
doing instead of responding to her
talking directly about him. Literally
[__] talking and raping the [__] out of
him. And this is what he's doing
instead.
The Oh my god, dude, she's like
squirming. Oh my god, she's squirming
and being reminded of Anna Effa.
Oh my god. Oh my god, she's like
squirming.
Bro, click on that channel real quick.
Click on that channel real quick and
look for the video that's about you,
little bro.
I read that. Sorry, guys.
>> Unk. Sorry, unk. [laughter]
Um there's some truth to that. All of my
All of my time revolves around my
daughter, but I love it. See, I Yeah.
Sorry, where did that go? Dude, posture
check. Posture check. Come on, get up.
Do the posture check. Uh
There's some truth
>> Dude, they just keep redeeming posture
check.
>> All of my time revolves around my
daughter, but I love it. See, I Yeah.
Like that's the point, right? Stop
hydrate.
daughter, but I love it. See, I
[laughter] Yeah.
Like that's the point, right? Stop it.
Stop it, you guys. Stop it.
That's the Yeah, that's the point. You
you Dude, I can't stress
>> And she's doing she's doing like an
obvious bit, too.
That's the other thing is she's
obviously playing up the interruption
like many streamers do. She's playing up
the interruption because while it is
slightly throwing her off, she's making
a joke out of it and making fun of it.
And Nick is like sitting here laughing
along with her. You know, it's clearly
He's almost like longing. Did you know
what I mean? He's almost like yearning,
you know? This is almost like yearning.
He's like laughing along with her like
you know, it's like they're having fun
together almost.
Curious enough, how she's not getting
any money for this.
>> a child because you you want that to be
your life, right? Obviously.
>> [laughter]
>> My god, I'm going to punch you guys
in the tit if you keep doing that.
If I found out my mom was arguing online
with Nazis and other scumbags, I would
be proud. [laughter]
Harassment be damned. I
There Empathy enjoyer and Josie clip
this is a [__] banger.
>> It's your kid, you know?
Yeah, this is such a banger that Cha-
channel points interruptions video is
such a banger.
Not the one about him, not the one about
him. This one's the banger. Thinking
you're the coolest person ever.
This is crazy.
>> I just like
Empathy
enjoyer dude, learn empathy 30 dude.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
They legit laugh at the same line for 5
years. For 5 years they've been laughing
at the same line. Dude, [__] hydrate
Anisa, drink water.
>> Once they become self-aware, then they
can make a decision on whether or not
like was my parent good or bad. She's
trying to talk about like complex
familial issues and they just keeps they
just keep redeeming hydrate. And then
they, you know, live their life. But I
think having
STOP. I'M GOING TO
PUNCH YOU IN [laughter] THE TIT.
I SWEAR. DUDE, HE'S like Anisa's biggest
fan on the right.
>> Moon child, I'll punch you in the tit. I
swear to Dude, what is the number that
it takes to do this? Is it like like 10?
Like how do they have so many channel
points?
>> You know you know he subbed and not on
Twitch. You know he subbed and not on
Twitch.
Tell them Mark, have a good night.
US Canada or a nation
>> So Felt it Inve is not Anisa, we've
proven it right here. There's a
different Felt it Inve that's the
chatter.
>> Shin that lets it's old and infirm
Unless that iDubbz is now running the
account when she's not around.
>> domains It's pa- Yeah, I mean that's
true. [laughter] Yeah.
You guys.
We love moral support. Not the tit.
[laughter]
Get a ring right now.
Oh god, stop.
Why am I so sweaty? Why You guys are
making me sweaty.
Dude, do they not have air conditioning
in their house? They both have this
problem.
>> me sweaty. Anyways Dude, Nick paying $50
to DM Anisa on Only Fans and talk to her
about Ian. This is research. Dude, this
is research. It's like Is tit a swear
word? I think so.
>> It's for It's for my stream.
>> I wouldn't say tit in front of my
loved one's children.
But I think this is pissing me off. How
do I make that stop? How do I do that?
Someone in chat is like, you know you
can disable that, but she probably
doesn't know. No, she definitely
doesn't.
Dude, what does that say?
My mom used to say freaking was a swear
word.
Like you are just watching ego just
chatting content, bro. She's not saying
anything. She's not talking about being
raped or something like you would
usually cover.
She's just sat there making a joke out
of being interrupted.
And you're sat there going
>> [laughter]
>> the whole time. You're just sat there
enjoying
your ex favorite content creator's
wife's ego just chatting content like
some pervert, like some fat [__]
pervert. Some ugly bastard ass pervert.
That's
That's what you're doing, bro. That's
all you're doing now. Moral support
queen.
I'll show you moral support.
Did she just flinch?
>> Moral support queen.
I'll show you moral
>> like Kino Casino, guys.
>> literally just flinch? I didn't even see
it until I got the [__] $300
donation. Woah, buddy. Now it's like
Kingston. Now it's like Kingston. At
least give me money if you're going to
do that. Dude, oh
Come on, bro. It's so What's the name of
the the guy?
>> It's literally
Nick
DiOrio watching me Nicholas DiOrio
watching Anisa Jo- Jo rightfully. Mr.
Oreo.
>> [laughter]
>> At least give me Dude, she's got the
[__] thing down. What All she needs
to like All she needs to have the
perfect combo here
is to just make money. money if you're
going to do that.
She's got to just inject the money. This
segment's perfect. She's just missing
the money.
I think tit's a bird, right?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh no, dude.
>> What is that? How do I turn that off?
That's so old.
>> [laughter]
>> Yo, imagine your next girlfriend seeing
this [__] bro. Imagine your Imagine
your next fat ass girlfriend seeing this
[__] seeing how happy you guys watching
this woman.
What is that? So wait, someone sent me
that [__] burnt peanut video.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, why are all of her channel goals
to like
uh Tehe posture check. Ooh, I got to do
a stretch.
I have a migraine, okay? Maybe that they
would stop redeeming it if you just did
the stretch.
>> I have a migraine.
Is this hell? Am I in hell?
This is the
What does that one say? No cursing.
Wait, she said hell and they immediately
just clapped it. What the [__]
Twitter was right. Making an Only Fans
made me
>> Nicholas, the goat.
>> is her arm and I'm in hell.
Be thankful [laughter] you get paid for
ear candy.
>> Thank you, Scrappin. Leg leg leg leg leg
leg leg leg leg leg leg leg mechanical
leg mechanical leg mechanical leg
mechanical leg mechanical leg mechanical
mechanical
>> love mechanical legs.
Bro, I'm doing the Game of Thrones thing
on Wednesday.
Yep.
>> That's crazy.
Oh. I can see it out the corner of my
eye. It's going to happen again, isn't
it? There's nothing you can do to stop
it. How do I
Oh wait, this is a gifted sub. Someone
Guys, 3 minutes and 43 seconds in we've
finally gotten one sub gifted to Anisa.
How do I make it stop? Somebody help me.
>> [laughter]
>> We were pointing this out in her first
stream that this could become a problem.
>> [laughter]
>> Ah. Okay. Wait. It is funny watching
people who just Like I mean there's
nothing like inherently bad about this
clip. It is funny though watching people
who don't stream go to Twitch cuz yeah,
I mean listen, they have a lot more
features, but the site isn't
Didn't she Wasn't she like a big
streamer for years?
I don't think she was a stream when
channel points were a thing though, to
be fair. I don't think the timeline
quite lines up there. But she was a big
streamer for years.
It It's just like Dude, he's such a
weirdo, bro. It does just like I don't
want to, you know, No is no. No is no
way this is weird. No is no way the
advice giving is weird.
Okay, I don't have to have to explain it
to retards who won't understand it. Like
super easy to use for like a normie who
doesn't know what the [__] they're
doing.
Right? They They act like everything is
so easy.
You ever think Anisa's sweat is
constantly running down his back just
sitting there? Big ball bearing sized
droplets of sweat smelling like chicken
soup in his room with pans catching it
under his chair? That's disco- That's
disgusting, man. You got the $10. Thank
you. 10 [__] minutes while your chat
is probably explaining exactly how to
fix it.
>> The [__] up. Wait, how do I
>> Is she stupid? Yes. Is this a problem on
Twitch's end?
>> Like watching like he's coaching her.
>> Yeah, probably. I mean, the UI should be
easy to like control, right? You
shouldn't have to have your chat tell
you how to do it. It should be like
right there.
>> Cut it off. I'm serious.
Stop. Let's go.
I have back sweat from this. I have back
sweat because my like cortisol
How do you have back sweat? Your chair
has got holes in it.
>> is all spiked and I'm like You guys are
going to Where did the cortisol spiking
thing come from? It's like everybody is
making this exact same comment for the
last week or so.
>> Guys, what what Guys, what's the
cortisol spiking thing? Cortisol going
through the roof. What Guys, what does
it mean? Me moon.
>> It's Streamlabs, I think. Face.
Yeah, but I have Streamlabs built into
OBS. So I can literally just mute all
sound with the click of a button or skip
an alert immediately. All you got to do
is put it into OBS.
Oh yeah, I can shut off the alert, huh?
Wait.
>> disable the alert there, but what I'm
saying is you can raise all the numbers
or just disable chat points entirely.
Like that's an It's a useless feature.
There's no value to this. I think
hydrate is a default.
Wait wait wait wait. No, but I But I
want PPP screamed at her cortisol levels
are spiking. Wait, so PPP made a joke
about that and Hasan [__] is saying it
on his show. Yeah, man. Yeah. Well,
Nick's chat is is so smart, aren't they?
And he's such a discerning guy. There's
no way PPP did not create the cortisol
thing.
>> Okay, he He has a right to say that.
>> everywhere.
Like Clavicular is saying that. Quick
boy. Quick boy. Yeah, what do you Okay,
where do you think it came from? Come
on, dude.
It is Clavicular, okay.
Quick [laughter]
boy, I'm scared.
>> Well, I haven't watched the new video by
Willy yet. Willy did a video on that.
>> Last time I went outside he was He was
on the Tik Toks.
Jesus, Nick, bro.
>> she should stretch and maybe they'll
stop. Wasn't that concerned about
hydrating.
Thank you for the $5. Thank you. I say
that I do not consume the manosphere
content. I do not consume the manosphere
content. I'm not lying to you. When I
see Sneako on stream and we're watching
a retrospective video about content from
3 years ago, I legit don't know any of
that [__] I'm not I'm not pretending
for the memes.
Bro, how the [__] is this still going?
I'm going to move the speed up a little.
Like it's taking too long for her to
figure it out.
K. Oh, wait. Wait. How are you Wait, how
are you doing it?
How are you doing it? Okay, redeeming.
Okay, let me go to Streamlabs. Why would
you go the I I Can you not Hold on.
Twitch I want to know if I'm right about
this. Twitch
disable channel points. I'm almost
positive you can just do that.
Navigate to viewer rewards, channel
points, toggle off enable channel points
option. It immediately stops viewers
from earning points and hides rewards.
Partners can disable the feature. Is she
not a partner?
>> I assume she's partner. Maybe that is my
fatal flaw is I assume Anissa partner.
Let me look. Yeah, she's partner. She
can do it. That's what I would have
done. I'm going to figure out how to
turn this off. Or is it Streamlabs? Like
there is no value to this this feature
at all. Elements? Is it Streamlabs or
Stream Elements? Or is it related to my
Twitch?
Why are you so lethargic? Yes, obviously
it's related to your Twitch, but it's
also Streamlabs. That's what's
making the sound. Lethargic.
>> [laughter]
>> You get the point here anyway. You get
the point. He just watches this dog [__]
content
and jerks off over it. He literally sits
there gripping his [__] to Anissa for 20
minutes instead of responding to a video
where she [__] talked him. It's It's
[__] absurd.
It's totally [__] absurd, guys.
On 75%
straight rubbing it raw under the desk.
This is Nick watching Anissa.
>> [music]
>> Nick watching Anissa with his
girlfriend. Nick putting Anissa on with
his girlfriend in the room.
I need the other one. That one's not as
good. I need the real guy nodding one.
The fat guy.
This is a guam video. This is a guam
video.
Let's talk about the orgasm gap.
According Let's not.
There's probably ants carrying leaves
and dish like that and his belly button
is like a carnivorous plant that mice
fall in and there is mouse skeletons in
there and dish and his flesh glistens
like dew. They have a $10 shmoney. Thank
you. You appreciate appreciate it.
>> [snorts]
[laughter]
>> It's like guam video. Back off.
This fruit guy's sick. This fruit guy's
[__] sick.